now we turn back to our top story
tonight and that is joe biden addressing
the nation about covert 19 the pandemic
even kind of taking credit for
everything the vaccines that he had
nothing to do with
uh without any thanks to the trump
administration no mention of when he
will hold the press conference
50 days and counting joining us now live
from the white house fox news white
house correspondent peter ducey
uh joe says he likes you will joe do a
sit down he said i don't
like the tough questions okay when do we
get ducey
versus joe i'm dying to see that and uh
maybe tomorrow uh it's a new day you
never know we can ask it doesn't hurt
you want to do an over and under on that
peter because i don't think you're gonna
win
uh well again you never know if you
don't ask but
uh sean we are doing some detective work
at the white house here
uh today the president said in the next
couple days he'll be able to take
reporter questions
jen saki has said he's gonna do a press
conference before the end of the month
that's march uh some back in the napkin
math 14
work days left in march we don't know
which one it is going to be but they
set a deadline for themselves now he
hasn't done a formal
solo press conference per se but on
january 25th
he did talk to reporters in a back and
forth for about
20 minutes uh during the campaign we
were with him all over the country
he only ever really did like an informal
gaggle and he took questions
and then once we got to wilmington they
would put them up on a stage
and they would take questions from five
reporters or so
every two or three weeks that was
a situation where they did have a
staffer off to the side with a
list of people to call on we were never
on the list but we still had a lot of
luck because he would listen for
uh my shouts at the end with the
questions about whatever
so my experience with biden has always
been that he likes to
mix it up he has told me on camera that
he knows that a hard question with an
edge is coming and
50 days does sound like a long time and
our brain room has
confirmed for us that that is the
longest a new president has gone in the
modern era without one of these press
conferences
however at one point during the
coronavirus lockdowns last year he went
89 days without a press conference it
was when he was
apart from the press corps for social
distancing reasons and he was not
traveling we could not get
close enough to shout uh the neighbors
there in wilmington would have been
really upset
if we were trying like that but uh
so 50 days a long time for a president
uh but maybe not for joe biden at least
based on recent history
one quick last question only have a
second does
circle back jinsaki circle back ever did
she get back to you
she does or somebody from the staff
does yes they circle what happens oh it
happens
i love circling back now if i send a
list of questions they don't seem to
answer my requests i'd love to interview
jen saki
she's welcome on for a full hour i have
a lot of questions for her
joe can have a full day i'll give him
three hours of radio and an hour of tv
see if he can hang all right peter ducey
thank you appreciate you being